a crowd of jubilant anti-government
protesters tears down a statue of Lenin
as the Ukrainian capital is gripped by
another night of mass demonstrations
hundreds gathered to witness this highly
symbolic moment some chanting
nationalist slogans whilst others set
about the stricken effigy with metal
bars and sledgehammers the focus of
their anger a decision by ukrainian
President Viktor Yanukovych not to sign
a far-reaching cooperation pact with the
European Union it's widely formed he
backs out of the deal which could have
paved the way to eventually you
membership after coming under severe
pressure from Moscow in the largest
gathering since this crisis started
hundreds of thousands of opposition
supporters flooded Kiev's Independence
Square on Sunday many waved EU flags and
shouted Ukraine is Europe opposition
leaders are calling for the resignation
of President Yanukovych together with
his Prime Minister and the entire
cabinet and they say they won't be
intimidated by the threat of a fresh
government crackdown we got an
information that this president will try
to impose a martial law and this is the
part of the deal between President Putin
and President Yanukovych we strongly
oppose any kind of can unconstitutional
actions that can be enacted by this
president in imposing any kind of mark
of martial law or curfew and we will
fight for our freedoms
for the second week running some
protestors threatened to march on the
presidential palace only a heavy cordon
of Ukraine special bear cooked
riot police prevented them from breaking
through
in a further development Russia state
gas supplier Gazprom has accused Ukraine
of falling behind with its payments and
some now fear a repeat of 2009 when
supplies were temporarily cut off
speaking a few days ago Russia's Prime
Minister Dmitry Medvedev made it clear
he would not stand for continued
meddling by his EU counterparts but in
rope National Park in the autumn if our
partner foreign ministers go to speak
with the leadership in the opposition
that's fine absolutely normally but in
fact they go right into the heart of
political events - an event that is
conducted against the existing rules
governing demonstrations taking part in
these events is and excuse me for saying
this a very simple case of interference
in another nations internal affairs
President Yanukovych has insisted he
does eventually want to see Ukraine
build closer ties with its European
neighbors but with ill-feeling reaching
an all-time high and neither side
showing any sign of backing down this is
a crisis which could get far worse Chris
Wade sky news